So case 1, the code that didn't cover is infeasible code.
The second case is the code that we believe to be feasible but which isn't worth covering.
A code might not be worth covering because it's very hard to trigger and it's very simple.
So let me give a quick example. The res variable is the result of the command to format a disc.
And if that operation fails, we'll just going to abort the program.
And so what might be the case is that we lack an appropriate fault injection tool
that will let us easily simulate the failure of a format disc call.
And in furthermore, the response of the code in this case is to
simply abort the execution of the program.
If those two things are the case, then we might be perfectly happy not to test this code branch,
and the reason is the abort code, which is going to terminate the entire application,
is presumably something that was tested elsewhere, so we don't have any real suspicion
that it might fail and there's no reason to think that calling it from a location like this
would act any differently or will probably be okay.